[Music]
this is Greek god x better known as
Greek and if you didn't recognize him I
wouldn't blame you cuz he used to look
like this the last year Greek has gone
on an unbelievable weight-loss journey
and turned into one of Twitch's biggest
stars in the process and after a
three-month hiatus he's returned with
content almost amazing as his new
physique buddy - for me Greeks travels
all the way from England to Austin Texas
to hang out with some of his best
friends and your favorite streamers
[Applause]
the guy's averaging roughly 16,000
viewers and fans tune in to see what
he's literally cooked up that day
Greeks back baby but dude I'm telling
you loose skin is way better than being
fattened a miserable for those of you
don't know Brik he's a twitch og and
before starting his own stream he was a
regular guest in troll on other channels
people like Tyler won and sodapoppin
Creek is driving god help us I'd rather
beat Nick right now I'm the best [ __ ]
driver in the world ok great ok
he was the lovable goof that nobody
really took seriously and when he showed
up in stream you knew the last were
coming
over the last few years he's gone from
sidekick - well superstar his
over-the-top personality and ability to
make everything funny has made Greek one
of the platform's most beloved streamers
[Music]
although his stream was going well
Greeks physical health wasn't and so he
decided to go on a weight-loss journey
alongside his Chad for the last year he
focused on fitness and diet I'm getting
a bit emotional because today I really
struggled with my diet that sounds
stupid but I really [ __ ] struggled
it's a mental thing it really is its
mental and I want to let you guys know
that you can do it too you should have
to stick to it every day and they
[ __ ] live it is killing me dude
but then Greek left for like three
months between spending time and his
grandparents farm trying to get a visa
to the US and dealing with some
unexpected health issues while Greek was
short on time after months of fans
crying for him to return what he did
before than ever
Greek traveled all the way to Austin
Texas to collaborate with somewhat
witches biggest stars and the results
are as funny as you'd expect it may but
he's not only providing some of your
favorite streamers with great content
he's also helping them get fit wait
[Music]
naked my finger please
Greeks infected both mischief and
sodapoppin with the healthy living bug
the ORS are loving these new streams and
he's become the third fastest growing
streamer on the platform these last few
weeks but the dude hasn't forgotten his
roots though giving fans some good old
gameplay and react streams as well
and while Greeks journey was difficult
he proved that as a streamer you can
take a break
focus on yourself and come back stronger
and more popular than ever thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]